Have you ever wondered how to make your
own physics simulated vehicles? Raycast
vehicles are often used in games to
simulate cars very well while being
simple and very performance at the same
time. Understanding and implementing
your own is very useful because you can
then adapt to any situation you might
need. So, let's take a look at how they
work and make our very own arcade style
car controller. In this first step,
we'll take a look at how the car
suspension works. First, let's take a
look at how a real spring works. A
spring is very simple. It has a rest
position where it wants to stay and it
applies a force trying to push or pull
it towards that rest position. This
force is given by the offset distance
times the spring stiffness. That's how
powerful or beefy the spring usually is.
The stronger it is, the higher the
force. Applying this force now our
spring will keep oscillating up and
down. To prevent they from being so
bouncy, real car suspensions uses what
is called a depth spring. You can think
of this as if the spring have to pass
through a very viscous liquid. The
faster the spring is moving, the harder
it makes it to move. So reduce the
spring force by the dumping strength,
how viscous this liquid is, times how
fast the spring is moving. A high
damping value will make it stop faster.
But make it too high and it will
actually slow down the speed the spring
returns to its rest position, which is
what's called an overdamped spring.
There is a way to know how high these
values can be before it affects the
returning speed, but we'll look at that
later. So playing around with these
values, we can create a very
good-looking damp spring that looks very
similar to a car suspension. A raycast
car is called like that because it uses
raycast pointing down instead of wheels
to simulate the spring suspension
interaction. The car itself is just a
block and the suspension forces are wet
at actually keeping them above the
ground. Now knowing that, let's start
making our car. Here's our humble scene.
Just a floor and some cameras. A raycast
car is completely physics based. So,
let's start by creating a new rigid body
3D. Let's put it above the ground and
create a mesh instance 3D to display the
car. Create a box
mesh and we'll be using two for X, 0.5
for Y, and four for Z. Making it about
the shape of a car. I'll also add a
material just so we can have some colors
to look at. Then, let's make another
mesh instance
3D and put it at the back of the
car. I will use 0.65. 65 0.4 and 1.8 for
the size. This is just so we can know
which way is the front and which way is
the back of the
vehicle. Then let's add a collision
shape 3D for the actual collision of the
rigid
body. Create a box
shape and set the size to two 0.5 and
four the same as the car body's
mesh. Now it's time to create our
suspensions.
Start by creating a new raycast
3D. Put it in the front of the car about
where the wheel spring would be. Here
I'm using minus 1.1 for the X and minus
1.3 for the Z position. And let's rename
it wheel L for front left. Then
duplicate it to create the back wheel.
I'll put this one in Z 1.3 and rename it
wheel RL for rear left.
Now let's duplicate both of the wheels
and put them on the other side and
rename them to FR for front right and RR
for rear left. With the car setup done,
let's create a new script for the car
and let's call it raycast
car. We'll start by declaring an export
variable wheels which is an array of
raycast 3D to keep track of our wheels.
For now, we'll also declare a variable
for the spring strength of 100 and
another one for the spring damping of
two. And finally, the one for the rest
position at 0.5. Since our targets
position has a length of one, the rest
position of 0.5 will make it stay in the
middle of that. Then let's create a
function called do single wheel
suspension that uses array cast. And on
the physics process, we'll iterate over
all of our wheels and call that. Now
save the file and add our wheels to the
script. Click on the add element four
times and select each of the wheels to
add them to the script. You can also
drag and drop them if you prefer. Now
let's begin with the physics. First, we
need to check if the wheel ray cast is
colliding. If it is, then we will apply
forces to the car using the spring
formula we just saw. We can get the
contact hit point where the raycast hits
the ground with suspension ray get
collision
point. We can get the spring up
direction be suspension ray. global
transform.basis.y. This is the direction
vector that will always point up from
the wheels perspective which is the
direction that the spring can move. And
to get how long the spring currently is,
we use spring length equals suspension
rate. global position distance to
contact.
And our offset is the rest distance
minus the spring
length. So using the spring formula, our
spring force is the spring strength
times the
offset. We convert that force value to a
3D directional vector by multiplying the
spring force by the spring up direction.
And we'll use that to apply forces to
the car. Now go apply forces uses an
offset position instead of a global
point. So our force offset position is
the actual point we want to apply the
force to minus the global position of
the rigid body. And now we can use apply
force to apply our spring force to our
suspension at the position where it hits
the ground. Let's activate the debug
collision shapes and play the game now.
And we have a very bouncy
car. You might have noticed a few
problems with this. We can change the
forces and see the results change. But
first let's implement our dumping force
like our 2D example. The dumping force
is the damp strength times the relative
velocity, which is how fast the spring
is moving. You can calculate the
relative velocity by saving the previous
spring position and calculate how fast
it has moved. But physics already has a
way to calculate that instantly. GDO
unfortunately doesn't expose this
function to dig this descript. But we
can easily make our own. So let's create
a function named get point velocity that
receives a point and returns a velocity
that point is moving at. This function
just returns the linear velocity plus
angular velocity dot crossc crossroduct
of the point minus the global position.
Don't worry about these values too much.
This is just a commonly used physics
formula. And let's make it return a
vector
tree. Now for our dumping force, we can
get a word velocity by using the get
point velocity with the contact
point. And we can calculate our relative
velocity. how much it has moved relative
to the wheels y-axis by using spring up
direction dot dot product word velocity
and our spring dumping force is the
spring dumping times the relative
velocity of the
spring. Now we just need to update the
force factor to subtract the dumping
force of the spring force before
multiplying it for the spring up
direction. And that's it for the main
physics part of the code. Now our car
bounces into a stop. We can adjust the
values and see how it changes.
Now, there's still one more problem we
need to fix. You might have realized,
but by using the spring formula as is,
our car is pushed down when the raycast
has hit the ground after the rest
distance. This gives the effect of
making the car stick to the ground. And
while some old arcade games use this
style, you might not want that. This is
especially bad if you have ramps or
loops in your game. When your car leaves
a ramp, the back wheels ray cast might
pull the car at the back, making it flip
more easily, or you might stay stick to
loops even if the car is not moving. To
remove that effect, you just need to
make sure your arrest distance is the
same as the recast target distance. This
way, the raycast will only detect when
the offset is negative. We'll take a
closer look at this later, but first,
let's give our car some real wheels.
Select the wheel ray cast and add a new
mesh instance
3D. Create a cylinder
mesh and set the top and bottom radius
to
0.4 and the height to
0.15. Then rotate it into the correct
orientation and move the real mesh to
the position where the rest distance is.
So minus 0.5 in the Y. You can also
favorite a property if you are using
Godo 4.4. This will put the position
always at the top in the inspector panel
which is very helpful. I'll put the
material here just so it has some
colors. Now copy the wheel mesh and
paste it inside all the other ray
casts. And there it is. Now we have
wheels. So let's hop back to the script
and make some changes. The modification
here is very simple. We need a new
variable for the wheel
radius and we need to subtract the
spring length with that.
Now we just need to position the wheel
visuals into the correct position. So
first let's rename all the wheels
instance mesh 3D to wheel. Then we can
find each ray cast wheels by calling
suspension ray.get node wheel and change
its
position. The spring
length using get node each frame is not
very good practice. We'll be changing
that in the second part when we refactor
the wheels into its own class. I have
also added a debug arrow here that I
made just so we can see it better, but
they are not needed. And let's also
rename some notes so it's easier to
read. In testing the game, our car has
working wheels. Now, this brake gas car
is completely physics based. So, to make
the car collisions react properly, we
want to make sure it has a proper mass
value. Let's change the mass to 50 kilos
and see what happens. Yeah, now our
springs are too weak. So, we need to
adjust the spring strength.
And that might have been too much. About
5,000 seems
right. And to fix the bounce, we also
increase the
damping. While trying random values
might be fun, there is an actual physics
formula that can get us a range of
damping values based on how springy we
want our car to be. After rearranging
the formula, we can get the damping
value based on the mass and the spring
force. It sounds complicated, but we
basically just need to change the ZA
value between 0 and one based on how
damp the spring is, and we get a dumping
force for that. You can use the formula
on W from alpha and change the values
for the mass and spring strength to get
the results. For very springy arcade
cars, I found the values between 0.1 and
0.2 are very nice, but more realistic
cars suspensions will probably use
values between 0.2 and 1.0. Now, the
last thing we need to do here is remove
the pulling force of the car. To do
that, let's just set the suspension
rate.target position.y to be minus the
rest distance plus the wheel radius.
This will make the rakecast works only
on negative offsets, completely removing
the pulling
force. But because we don't have that
pulling force anymore, now the car is a
lot more bouncy. So, we need to increase
our dumping force to counteract that. By
changing the raycast length dynamically,
we can change the car's rest position at
runtime and see its effect.
And if you want to, we can add a small
pulling force to the car, just enough to
make it stick to the ground a bit. It's
as easy as adding an offset here that
will allow the spring to extend over its
rest distance. And we now got a small
ground pulling force. But let's remove
that. And that's it. That's the
suspension part of the Raycast car done.
Next part, we'll take a look at the
acceleration of our car and we will
refactor the wheels into its own
component to make custom modifications
later easier. If you'd like to support
me, you can get all the files used in
this tutorials on Patreon. I hope you
like this video and until next time.